[Musica]
la fiducia
cos'è la fiducia e quel sentimento umano
che consiste nei presuppori un
atteggiamento o un comportamento
adeguato da parte di altri individui o
da noi stessi Diciamo che possiamo
vedere la fiducia in due modi la fiducia
condizionata è quella incondizionata la
prima è quella che si basa
sull'efficacia delle persone per esempio
un datore di lavoro ha fiducia nei suoi
collaboratori non tanto come sono di
persona ma bensì sul loro operato e sui
loro risultati mentre la seconda si basa
sull'essenza delle persone ossia sul
comportamento umano
la fiducia è considerata uno degli
aspetti più importanti di qualsiasi
relazione che sia essa d'amicizia
lavorativa o affettiva d'altronde la
parola fiducia deriva da latino Fides
Che significa
riconoscimento dell'affidabilità
dell'altro e anche un sentimento di
tranquillità e di sicurezza quando non
ci fidiamo perché abbiamo paura
paura di essere delusi dagli altri ma
anche da noi stessi Ecco perché molto
difficile fidarsi e si dice che la
fiducia va guadagnata è un sentimento
profondo che non può essere regalato
e quando manca la fiducia Ecco che entra
in gioco
l'incertezza sugli altri ma che su noi
stessi
Io in passato ho avuto veramente
difficoltà a fidarmi degli altri
e a provare questo sentimento il mio
vissuto mi ha portato spesso a essere
molto diffidente negli altri ma non
avevo fiducia neanche in me stessa una
delle mie più grandi diffidenze era
proprio verso il cibo
soprattutto quando sono arrivata in
Italia ho fatto veramente fatica a
mangiare perché non conoscevo i prodotti
lo conoscevo gli ingredienti lo so può
sembrare paradossale visto che la gente
mi conosce e soprattutto
dopo che ammazzo sono diventata appunto
MasterChef Italia
come molti sapranno perché ne hanno
sentito dire durante il programma Ho
letto in qualche intervista che ho
rilasciato sono data in Nigeria
Precisamente a Benin City in the state e
sono arrivata a Verona a Mazzo di 2006
insieme alla mamma e a fratello
Ricordo come se fosse ieri il mio primo
approccio verso il cibo italiano
eravamo in aereo quindi dovetti ancorare
il territorio italiano le hostess ci
serviranno dei panini col prosciutto
la prima difficoltà perché Nigeria non
c'è
l'usanza non è cultura
usare i salumi Anzi non esistono Quindi
io presi il mio panino lo Guardai lo
osservai lo annusay tocca il prosciutto
e non mi piacquero nella consistenza nei
colori tanto meno i profumi Infatti non
assaggia il nulla
oggi Invece mangerei salumi tutti i
giorni a qualsiasi ora Devo darmi dei
limiti ogni tanto un altro esempio fu la
pasta anche questa non rientra tagliati
abitudini dei nigeriani si mangia per lo
più come contorno
assaggiandola qui come si deve mi si è
aperto il mondo sono diventata pasta
dipendente
ed è diventato uno dei miei comfort food
devo dire che non è stato difficile
crescere e vivere in Italia perché sono
sempre stata molto curiosa sin da
piccola e poi assaggiando diversi
prodotti diversi piatti tradizionali non
potevano innamorarmi della cucina
italiana e piano piano È cresciuta la
mia passione per il cibo una passione
che era già andata Nigeria anzi diciamo
che lì cucinare è una cosa normalissima
dei bambini e Fin da piccole devono
imparare a essere autonome Per quanto
riguarda il cibo infatti lì guardavo mia
mamma le mie zie cucinare e io cucinavo
non per passione ma per necessità quindi
la cucina intesa come combinazione di
Sapori
equilibrio tra ingredienti e l'estetica
lo ha preso qui in Italia questo grazie
al mio compagno Samuele che al mio
fianco da oltre 10 anni che mi
incoraggiava e mi costringeva Sì ad
assaggiare piatti diversi devo dire
anche i gatti a sua mamma la mia suocera
che mi ha fatto conoscere e innamorare
della cucina veneta e Veronese e la
guardavo sempre a preparare questi
piatti tipici della domenica e piano
piano Ho imparato e fino è arrivata a
farmi entrare nella sua cucina per dare
una mano quindi
Tra tutto questo osservare assaporare
diversi ingredienti assimilavo nuovi
sapori e mi sono resa conto che
io ho tanti ingredienti li mangiavo in
Nigeria per esempio fegato la farina di
mais i fagioli le frattaglie e così via
e mi piaceva l'idea di fare incontrare
le due culture quella nigeriana e quella
italiana di associare i sapori nelle mie
origini a quelli dei piatti tradizionali
italiani ma soprattutto quelli del
Veneto
poi è arrivata la pandemia
Però è stato proprio in quel momento che
ho messo come si suol dire le mani in
pasta e una sera la mia amica Letizia ha
deciso di scrivervi a Masterchef da solo
non avrei mai mai mai fatto non avevo
abbastanza fiducia nelle mie capacità
non avrei avuto il coraggio abituato con
me Ero a vivere sempre con i freno
tirato
per paura di deludere gli altri ma
soprattutto me stesso
invece mi sono fidata di lei insomma la
mia amica da quasi 10 anni ho deciso di
tentare superato tutti i casting e sono
entrata nella masterclass magia è
cambiato qualcosa È come se in me si
fosse riacceso un fuoco che era spento e
fino a quel momento non sapevo o non
pensavo che io fossi così combattiva e
competitiva
che dire Sono qualcuno mi chiedeva ma tu
no io non sono competitiva però
rivedendomi ho detto Wow ok
tanti Mi hanno chiesto se mi aspettassi
di vincere
devo assolutamente no mi davo della
sfavorita da sola
perché pur conoscendo la bravura e il
talento dei miei compagni ma veramente
io non avevo paura di nessuno di loro
non temevo nessuno io avevo paura di me
stessa sapendo quanto
sono emotiva e sensibile ha detto ecco
mi farò fuori da sola
e invece piano piano Ho iniziato a
crederci ho iniziato a pensare che
potevo farcela insomma
Bastava solo impegnarmi tanto cucinare
con fantasia
e preparare dei piatti gustosi anche con
ingredienti che non conoscevo
in questo contesto ho imparato una
lezione sulla fiducia
che tutto è possibile
poi ho ripensato
a quella ragazzina sull'aereo che aveva
paura del prosciutto
chissà cosa avrebbe pensato adesso se le
avessero detto che un giorno sarebbe
stato in grado di cucinare con
ingredienti mai visti
altro che prosciutto non avrei mai
immaginato di riuscire a fare qualcosa
con l'idrolato di rosmarino
Insomma potrei stare qui a raccontarvi
tanti aneddoti
ho capito che
non sempre ciò che non conosciamo debba
per forza no
ho capito che Bisogna lottare bisogna
impegnarsi
e che bisogna avere un atteggiamento di
apertura nei confronti di ciò che la
vita come non ha Mystery box ci riserva
a Masterchef ho capito che appunto tutto
è possibile Ho bisogno di avere paura di
fare qualcosa bisogna provare non si sa
mai come può andare a finire
Io ci ho provato
ho capito che se è fiducia in te stesso
hai anche la forza per inseguire i tuoi
sogni a me è successo
ci ho sperato Ci ho creduto e mi sono
impegnato tanto ho sempre lavorato
tantissimo e sempre cercato di dare il
massimo e tutto quello che ho fatto
nella mia vita e tutte queste esperienze
hanno temprato il mio carattere resa più
forte e combattiva
quando sono arrivata in finale Ho deciso
che nel mio menù ci fosse Tracy che mi o
meno doveva rispettare la persona che
sono il mio vissuto il mio percorso
tutto quello che mi ha portato lì
la Nigeria e l'Italia l'abbraccio tra le
due culture
che alla fine mi ha portato la vittoria
è fantastico ed è sorprendente
contrastare
quanto la fiducia in se stessi negli
altri possa portare delle cose belle lo
so è difficile molto difficile sono la
prima di non è facile fidarsi degli
altri e trovare quella forza dentro di
noi per provare a fare qualcosa che ci
piace anche qualcosa di nuovo
ma bisogna farlo bisogna trovare quel
fuoco bisogna di accenderlo
poi credo che in questo caso come dicevo
prima essendo una persona molto
sensibile molto emotiva cucinare mi
abbia aiutato perché per me il cibo È
emozione
cucinare per gli altri è una forma
d'amore si dice no Quindi per me
cucinare per gli altri è un modo per
aprirmi gli altri è un modo per far
entrare gli altri nel mio mondo
per me Mangiare non è solo devo nutrirmi
cosa che facevo battute in Nigeria sono
mangiare si mangia Perché mangiare è uno
dei bisogni primari dell'uomo
invece io potrei definire il mio
rapporto con il cibo quasi spirituale
Come dico sempre non mangio per nutrire
il mio corpo ma Maggio ben nutrire
l'anima perché mi rende felice
può sembrare magari una frase grande ma
è così o l'omaggio
Non lo so sento sento
qualcosa dentro quel calore
Io stasera ho voluto portare
la mia esperienza personale sulla
fiducia
se qualcuno di voi ricorderete il mio
menù alla finale l'ho chiamato abbraccio
un gesto un gesto semplice che però
possiamo considerare come
come una fiducia
l'abbraccio può essere fiducia perché è
un sinonimo di dare e ricevere anche
questo in passato facevo veramente
fatica invece lì a Masterchef vicino la
mia diffidenza
ho iniziato a baciare tutti così
e devo dire che ho scoperto veramente
quanto è bello dare e ricevere un
abbraccio questa fosse stata una delle
più grandi conquiste tant'è che sono
uscita con dei legami di amicizia in
così poco tempo non è mai successo in
tutta la mia vita
se avete fiducia in voi stessi
ispirerete fiducia agli altri
non Aspettate che siano gli altri a
dirvi bravi
ogni tanto guardatevi allo specchio e
ditemi bravi
non soffermatevi sui problemi
cercate la soluzione
Io l'ho fatto
ed eccomi qua sono
e sarò sempre la vincitrice di
MasterChef Italia 11 Grazie
[Applauso]